así era entre Colombia y Venezuela y
entre Colombia El Ecuador
en donde nosotros llegamos a exportar
bienes de alto valor agregado
industriales manufactureros fue
precisamente en la comunidad andina en
general Y en primerísimo lugar en
Venezuela
esa realidad económica que podría ser el
factor de la industrialización
es decir del Progreso real de Colombia
tenemos hoy que aprovechar la
profundizarla
Venezuela ha pedido su ingreso a la
comunidad andina y lo mismo ha hecho la
República de Chile
y un poco más lejana se acerca la
República de Argentina
si diéramos ese paso
creo que Colombia estaría construyendo
su plataforma de Progreso económico más
importante después de su propio mercado
interno
por esta carretera se podría llegar Si
hubiera un acuerdo
el embajador de Venezuela de nuestro en
Venezuela va a tener que acometer esa
tarea
hasta que fundemos una embajada en
Guyana
la posibilidad de que estos camiones y
las personas en general puedan llegar
hasta allá
en donde hoy se presenta el crecimiento
económico más importante de toda América
del Sur por descubrimientos de campos
petroleros con una población un poco
ajena a nuestra tradición étnica
hindúes afros pero que posibilitan
realmente la construcción del mercado
común en América del Sur y ojalá por el
sur podamos llegar hasta la Patagonia
Ojalá un camionero
modificando las normas
una Camionera porque no pueda llegar
hasta allá a Georgetown por un lado
incluso hasta el Brasil y por el otro
lado hasta la Patagonia donde los
puertos vientos son constantes y
cotidianos
si lo hace un camionero una Camionera lo
podrá hacer cualquier familia cualquier
persona en moto
reconociendo que esta es nuestra casa
y que no tenemos que ponernos a cerrarle
las puertas a nuestra propia casa
a cualquiera se le ocurriría una locura
hacia el interior de su casita de su
apartamento le cerrara las puertas a una
habitación a la cocina o a la sala
si algo tenemos es esta casa y esta casa
nos puede permitir la prosperidad yo
deseo que las primeras personas
beneficiarias
sean las que habitan al lado y lado de
la frontera
las que se arriesgaban en esas trochas
las mujeres que caminaban por allí
prácticamente dependiendo de
funcionarios que incluso llegaban a
cobrar peaje de bandas
de todo tipo multi crimen que podían
matar que podían violar Hoy hay una
recuperación automática para los
transeúntes Hace unos días para quienes
van en máquinas ahora y es legalizar
completamente los flujos culturales de
población y económicos eso debe redundar
en un salto
cualitativo en materia de Derechos
Humanos en toda la frontera Colombo
venezolana
debe redundar lo mediremos lo
evaluaremos públicamente en un aumento
de la calidad de vida
el que Cúcuta se haya vuelto una de las
ciudades más pobres de Colombia tiene
que ver con un desastre humanitario al
otro lado y con otro desastre
humanitario a este lado que este puente
de cemento sea el inicio Ojalá con el de
tienditas que dentro de pocas semanas se
va a inaugurar mucho más grande sea no
solamente un puente de cemento
sino la vía por la cual se construya El
Progreso de estas dos regiones del
táchira del norte de Santander de
Santander que no solamente pase como lo
vimos
las grandes cantidades de toneladas de
aluminio y de acero y por otro lado
las medicinas porque el camión
colombiano iba cargado de medicinas sino
que también pase la producción del norte
de Santander de Santander pase la panela
pase la guayaba en plena campaña me
quedé allá en unas casas de la región y
de eso hablábamos pase las confecciones
pase el calzado pase las cosas que
podamos con la imaginación
[Aplausos]
producir aquí que ya no sean 400
millones de dólares como el ministro de
comercio me dice que
más o menos de contrabando van pasando
con cobros de peajes durísimos por las
trochas sino que pasemos a los mil
millones de dólares que pasemos Ojalá al
final de este gobierno a 4000 y que en
el mediano plazo logremos recuperar los
8.000 que antes pasaban la mayoría de
mercaderías colombianas hacia Venezuela
pero indudablemente necesitamos de su
acero de su aluminio
necesariamente las dos economías tienen
que integrarse estamos hablando de una
zona especial
entre el táchira y norte de Santander
para que sea plataforma de la
industrialización
para que
la calidad de vida sea general si no no
tendría mucha gracia porque veríamos
pasar las tractomulas con riquezas de
otros lados quizás ni siquiera de
Colombia y seguir aquí en las mismas
condiciones en donde el hambre avanza
donde las necesidades básicas y
satisfechas están sin resolver la gracia
del comercio es que traiga Progreso para
la población y yo estaré midiendo eso
Ojalá la migración
que en más Sabino de Venezuela aquí como
antaño fue la de Colombia ya
pueda hoy tener calma
las personas que deseen vivir en
Colombia
el respeto de todos sus derechos pasar
de simplemente un carnet a una real
vivencia de derechos plenos Como
ciudadanos venezolanos acogidos en
Colombia
en el Ministerio de Educación he pedido
en el icfes exactamente que se agilicen
completamente los trámites para
homologar diplomas y ojalá se haga lo
mismo al otro lado porque lo primero que
tenemos que lograr es que una venezolana
que tenga títulos un venezolano con su
debida preparación pueda trabajar en
Colombia y lo mismo un colombiano una
colombiana en Venezuela
Este es un tema de primer orden porque
al final las sociedades enriquecen no
solamente por el comercio sino
fundamentalmente por la educación
tendremos nuevas
tareas y nuevos problemas que asumir
habrá indudablemente discusiones
obstáculos
entre los dos gobiernos y las dos
sociedades
pero siempre en paz siempre con el
argumento siempre respetando al otro la
autodeterminación de los pueblos es una
orden de la Constitución de Colombia
todos sus gobernantes y a sus ciudadanos
y ciudadanas
lo que pase en el desarrollo político de
Venezuela Antes que nada debe ser
determinado por el mismo pueblo de
Venezuela igual que lo que nos pase a
nosotros los colombianos en materia
política debe ser determinado libremente
por el pueblo colombiano que la
democracia que la paz que el respeto
absoluto a la dignidad del ser humano
allá y acá sean nuestra Consigna común
al norte de Santander le entregamos este
hecho en las primeras días de este
gobierno
poder normalizar su situación cotidiana
y hacer de esos puentes y del hecho de
estar en la frontera la palanca mayor de
la prosperidad económica y del bienestar
general muy amables a todas y todos por
haberme escuchado